there's so much
to being asian that i remember
being ashamed about that's probably the
worst part it's just
wishing for news to stop increased
attacks on asia but knowing it's not
going to
but i also sometimes get frustrated when
i'm defined as an asian actress because
my personal story is not like
asian the narrative of the asian
american experience right now
is very multifaceted in order to
represent it fully
i cannot personally just tell a story it
has to come from so many different
people
as you all know this past year we've
seen an unfortunate rise in anti-asian
sentiment
and also hate crimes against the asian
american pacific islander community
we've partnered with youtube originals
and lebron james spring hill company to
create recipe for change
it's a one hour special that involves
three different dinner conversations
including
some of your favorite aapi celebrities
we talk about what we can do
to actually create change given what
we're seeing in the world but not only
that we felt like that wasn't enough
that we wanted to hear from you directly
so we asked for you to share some of
your secrets your experiences and what
you're dealing with as young asian
american pacific islanders
and we've decided to create an episode
of seeking secrets
my mom is fully filipina ever since the
rise of violence on aapi community
members
my mom has asked me to go out and run
her errands for her she's been
especially afraid to go to asian markets
by herself
now as we're entering adulthood or we're
in adulthood um
we feel responsible for our parents
instead of our parents being responsible
for us
and i think with the rise of anti-asian
hate um
this has really became real
i've never had so much fear of where my
parents are at any given time
and what and what might happen to them
so recently more and more tv series and
movies are featuring asian american
actors
however many of the asian actors tend to
be half asian
it upsets me because it seems like
producers still want people who still
look
a little white it's almost like they are
averse to casting asians who look
undeniably asian
obviously someone who is half asian
won't look like me so i still don't feel
represented
i relate to this a lot but i always try
to be a little
sensitive to what to what my mixed
friends go through all the time because
there's also this not enoughness thing
that goes on
and so it's you know i don't think any
of us win unless we're all
like we're all just equally represented
and not
fulfilling some quota being half white
and half korean i've never felt korean
enough
when the atlanta shootings happened all
my friends were checking in on my full
asian friends
but didn't address me in any way i felt
like i was not allowed to grieve because
i'm not
quote asian enough even though the women
who were killed look just like my mom
i wish i looked less asian
when i look in the mirror i see facial
features that could be fixed with
plastic surgery
my flat nose slender eyes round
cheekbones
yellow skin the asian beauty standard
seems to want nothing to do with these
features but it belongs to us
yet i still want them gone trust me as
somebody
who embodies a lot of the typical asian
features
it took me a while to learn to love them
but i
do love myself you know i just i hope
that you can get to that point because
you are beautiful and i hope that you
can realize that
sometimes i wish i could find out more
about my culture
but i'm never accepted into aapi spaces
because i'm not fully asian
i'm scared that i won't be able to pass
on my chinese indonesian
heritage to my children i can't speak
the language
can't cook the food and i've only met my
grandparents and extended family three
times in my entire life
chinese indonesian jindo that's
what i am but um i mean i get that wow
so much
for those of you who don't know i have a
six month old right now
and he's mixed i've been very blessed
that my parents
can come over and and speak to him in
indonesian
um but i can't cook the food
as a child i refused to eat the
vietnamese food my mom cooked for me at
school
i would starve myself during school
lunches because the other kids in my
class continuously bullied me for eating
strange food
ah this this hits me this is exactly how
i felt when i was a kid
the type of food that you eat at home
shows so much about who you are
and where you come from and it tells a
lot of you about your story
be proud of that be proud of the food
that you eat be proud of your culture
and yeah you have the best lunch box so
i'm jealous
i grew up in a very old-fashioned
chinese family when i was 16 i had my
first girlfriend and she was black
when i told my parents that she wasn't
chinese my mom and dad threatened to
disown me if i didn't break up with her
she dumped me before i ever got the
chance to even talk about it
and now i'm afraid to date anyone who is
not chinese
in a lot of ways our parents generation
or grandparents generation can be a bit
old-fashioned
it doesn't make it okay but they come
from a very different time and different
place
but i think part of our job as asian
americans is to help bridge that gap
my mom is a catholic filipina and she
isn't very accepting of lgbtq plus
people
i'm bisexual and i've decided that i
will never come out to my mom because i
don't want to disappoint her
why mess up her perfect image of me now
well first of all congratulations on
being queer
you are already a gift to the world um i
think that
one thing that really stands out is this
word perfect
i think that you have to realize that
you're already perfect
the church your parents
uh your culture if any of it is telling
you
that you're imperfect because you're
queer
then that's a problem with the system
and that's a problem with their
perspectives
you have to make sure that at the
beginning you are saying no i'm already
perfect
as a bisexual person i'm always
questioning whether it is worth being
independent from my asian family and
living my own life
even though they seem to encourage me to
find my own way they also instilled the
toxic mindset
that i need to stay and take care of
them even if it means i don't live the
life
i want it was interesting because our
family's not as affectionate
like we didn't grow up hugging or saying
i love you
and it was funny because my mom had a
really great relationship with her
father
and he had never really told her that he
loved her
but she always knew always knew that he
loved her so
much and he didn't need to tell her and
she was like that's the difference
in our culture is that we don't have to
say it
we just live it i tried killing myself
when i was 16. i sat on the kitchen
floor
sobbing with a razor blade in my hand my
family never knew
to this day they think my scars were
just clumsy
accidents i never told them because
mental illness
has always been taboo in asian
households
like my own mental illness in our family
was something that was hard to talk
about it remains hard in our community
it remains hard in our broader society
we're constantly told that we're bad or
that we
are less than or that we're imperfect
because of our
identities just live your life live your
life for you
be proud of who you are your parents
worked
so hard to be able to give you this
opportunity to grow up
and to pursue your dreams to the best of
your ability
be proud of that be proud of their story
and be proud of who you are
you belong and own your asian-ness and
be unapologetic about it
hey y'all thank you so much for watching
this episode of seeking secrets
make sure you check out the link in
description below for recipe for change
it's a one-hour special that involves
three different dinner conversations
including some of your favorite aapi
celebrities
including lisa ling simul new we have
hassan minaj
olivia munn and many many more and we
really gather to talk about issues that
pertain to our community
we hope you enjoy the special